come on
welcome to the trenches battlefield one
is taking us from closed corridor sword
fights the wide open air in five planes
dice has been slowly releasing details
for the multiplayer game modes and
campaign here's everything confirmed so
far Danny Berlin told GameSpot that the
single-player campaign will more
accurately reflect battlefields open
sandboxes locations for the multiplayer
and single-player campaigns will cross
pads but you will battle it out on the
Western Front as well as inside
fortresses across the deserts of Arabia
players will follow multiple characters
from different backgrounds in the
trailer there's a Bedouin woman warrior
on a horse she is playable in the
single-player campaign on to multiplayer
battles will play out on Hills wide
fields and of course trenches
battlefield one will focus on sandbox
combat in 64 player multiplayer battles
in new and classic game modes there will
be the rock-paper-scissors combat
strategy battlefield is known for within
ground sea and air combat options for
the ground you're looking at light tanks
heavy tanks armored trucks some of the
all-terrain vehicles are some of the
biggest in the series an entire squad
can fit into some of the bigger tanks
yes you can ride horses they'll be
similar to motorcycles in the sense that
you'll be using them Scout foresee
battleships are also entirely
controllable these ships do damage
behind closed doors gameplay showed a
player controlling a dreadknot which is
Royal Navy battleship and leveled an
entire shoreline this also confirms that
levels will have extensive
destructibility biplanes try planes and
bombers are happening Berlin stated you
can have these dogfights with multiple
people in planes your buddy is in the
rear seat shooting back at the guy while
you fly alongside a bomber clearing the
way for your troops they also confirmed
there will be airships but currently
there's no confirmation if that airship
is a Zeppelin there's also a stronger
focus on melee combat in fact dice
designs the hand-to-hand combat from the
ground up for battlefield one complete
with a bayonet charge ability sabers
trench clubs and shovels it's been
confirmed there will be a persistent
squad system so you'll be able to take
your buddies with you to other matches
also battlefield one will have a server
browser but it wasn't confirmed
it's PC only or it will be offered on
consoles to the game will be made using
the Frostbite engine which is the same
engine used for battlefield for a beta
has been confirmed for sometime later
this year by registering as a
battlefield insider which is free you
can get into the beta early battlefield
one launches on October 21st for ps4
xbox one and pc people with EA or origin
access membership or those who pick up
the deluxe edition can get it early
October 18 North America gets a retail
release but no disc it's digital that's
everything confirmed so far but be sure
to stay tuned to gamespot for the latest
on battlefield life
you